actualizamos la información económica
con Juan Pablo lucum y Juan Pablo saludo
nuevamente para usted acá estamos otra
vez vamos a comenzar con América Latina
hablar de temas a veces trae
consecuencias y las autoridades de
Bolivia tuvieron que advertir a sus
ciudadanos por especular sobre el dólar
cuéntenos Así es así funciona a veces la
economía se comenta se dice y pues en
este caso recientemente ha habido una
inusual demanda de dólares debido a
rumores que están generando
incertidumbre en la población las
autoridades bolivianas dijeron que
algunos ciudadanos y analistas
económicos están especulando sobre una
supuesta restricción de la venta de
dólares en el sistema financiero algo
que no ha sido confirmado ni anunciado
por las entidades financieras del país
el resultado de todo esto ha sido una
alta demanda de dólares en el sistema
financiero y Por ende un cambio drástico
en su precio respecto a la moneda local
con esto las autoridades de supervisión
del sistema financiero advirtió que
algunas personas podrían ser procesadas
penalmente se divulgan falsa al respecto
y seguimos esperando el resultado de la
reunión entre Úrsula labor del deien y
Richi sunaka para hablar del acuerdo de
Irlanda del Norte Mientras tanto Qué le
parece si seguimos con la revisión de la
economía en Reino Unido Ángela hay mucha
especulación también sobre este tema hay
mucha pues se espera todo esta reunión y
se espera también que es lo que se va a
dar de este espacio discusiones en las
que también se espera que el nuevo
acuerdo aborde las tensiones comerciales
y permita facilitar los controles
físicos de los bienes que exigía la
Unión Europea en virtud del acuerdo
original más temprano el gobierno
británico dijo abro comillas el Primer
Ministro quiere asegurarse de que
cualquier acuerdo solucione los
problemas drásticos sobre el terreno
garantice el comercio que fluya
libremente en todo Reino Unido proteja
el lugar de Irlanda del Norte en nuestra
Unión y devuelva la soberanía al pueblo
de Irlanda del Norte cierro comillas
Mientras tanto revisamos otras esferas
como usted lo decía de la economía de
Reino Unido porque este se enfrenta la
escasez de frutas y hortalizas que ha
obligado a los principales supermercados
a introducir medidas de racionamiento
según el gobierno la situación se ha
derivado de las malas condiciones
meteorológicas Mientras que otros
apuntan a los altos precios de la
energía veamos
estantes de verduras vacíos en algunos
de los supermercados más grandes de
Reino Unido tomates pimientos pepinos se
encuentran entre los productos que
escasean donde hay algunos disponibles
están siendo racionados
tenemos que conformarnos con estas Por
ahora hasta que vuelvan
la escasez se debe a varios factores los
supermercados y el gobierno han señalado
a las malas condiciones meteorológicas
en los principales países exportadores
España y Marruecos donde el frío inusual
y las inundaciones han afectado el
rendimiento de las cosechas pero los Los
costos de la energía también han
obligado a los productores nacionales a
reducir el uso invernaderos para los
cultivos estacionarios
este año ha sido aún peor debido al
precio del gas y a que muchos
cultivadores no plantan normalmente a
estas alturas ya tenemos pepinos
ingleses en producción pero no los hay
si es que hay alguno en este momento Así
que creo que eso ha empeorado el
problema otros también apuntan a la
escasez de mano de obra y a las barreras
comerciales relacionadas con el brexit
señalando que los países de la Europa
continental no parecen enfrentarse a los
mismos problemas el ministro de medio
ambiente de Reino Unido afirma que es
probable que la escasez persista Durante
las próximas dos o cuatro semanas por lo
que sugiere a los británicos que
recurran alternativas locales como los
nabos y en relación con este tema que
hay de los indicadores Ángela
precisamente empezamos con las bolsas
europeas porque Siguen operando con el
fusil que es el índice bursátil de
referencia de la bolsa de valores de
Londres reportando las bolsas asiáticas
cerraron en negativo movidas por las
previsiones de la actividad fabril de
China y las declaraciones del gobierno
del Banco Central de Japón
ahí justamente Le quiero preguntar sobre
las declaraciones del nuevo jefe del
Banco Central nipona pues revisemos las
este lunes el académico de 71 años que
el Primer Ministro japonés propuso como
próximo gobernador del Banco Central
dijo que tenía algunas ideas sobre cómo
salir del estímulo masivo de la economía
que ha tenido efectos negativos en el
funcionamiento del mercado Porque
mientras los bancos de la mayoría de
países aumentan los tipos de interés
como lo hemos visto acá en América
Latina en Estados Unidos en Japón
funciona completamente distinto caso su
edad dijo que estima que le una
inflación por encima del 0% pero por
debajo del 2% en este momento la tasa se
ubica en el 4,3% anual en enero
escuchemos
la inflación tendencial debe aumentar
significativamente para que el Banco
Central de Japón considere endurecer la
política monetaria están surgiendo
varios efectos secundarios pero la
política actual es necesaria y apropiada
para lograr su objetivo de inflación del
2%
cerremos con su cifra del día
3.447 millones de dólares es el nuevo
récord en la inversión extranjera
directa en 2022 esto en Estados Unidos
en México Perdón un dato que supera por
mucho la cifra prepadémica de los 1091
millones de dólares e incluso la del
pico más alto de 2017 cuando fue de
1645 millones de dólares ni siquiera la
mitad Juan Pablo gracias a ustedes y nos
vemos mañana mañana